anything it's like I'm like a lowering
gameplay audio and there's no key hello
folks
happy Monday joined by John Luke here
who's gonna be driving our dark souls
remastered experience here so we have
the game early we've had the game early
we could have stream last Friday
actually but then we had some stuff
going on so we're streaming today
instead the interesting thing is we're
not allowed to do like shortcuts so if
you if I'm gonna start off by saying if
somebody asks about shortcuts that's why
yes so just fight despite this game
being seven years old they had some
pretty specific like don't go here don't
go here which alright whatever but yeah
that means there are certain shortcuts
we can't take mm-hmm
which is funny because they're actually
the shortcuts I usually pick so I don't
like lookup like okay how do you how are
you supposed to like normally do it in
quotes
follow the path I just beat the
gargoyles this is where rats
okay I'm gonna ring the bell got a ring
it and then we're gonna head to the
lower undead burg and fight ourselves
Capra demon sounds good to me
just so you guys know too the game comes
out Friday and it is $39.99 for the
console switches delayed yep and I don't
know if there's did you see a price for
that one I didn't see what PC also you
get it 50% off I think if you are you
end it yes PC if you want it yeah but I
think someone made a decent comment
earlier which is like this probably
isn't the like would you buy this if you
had it on PC already you know like the
the the only reason I would is if the
servers are I mean I imagine the server
so separate if I'm really interested in
wanting to like play with like a very
populated online community and I was
really interested in that kind of stuff
okay
otherwise yeah I mean like it's okay but
like a if you've already played Dark
Souls like on PC like there's not it's
the same game I think this is largely
for those people who like plated on 360
where it was running it like sub like 10
frames a second at times and are people
who've never played it and so that's
kinda what this thing's for as much as I
would have loved a like Shadow the
Colossus level
rameneh that's not what this is no hello
oh hey I forgot my greetings
this is the one that I remember the
least of the NPCs this game has like so
many NPCs in the covenants that like
leads away like gear and quests and I
barely remember how anything I don't
know anything about this one didn't play
I was using it as an excuse to like
potentially come and play this one but
even then I'm not even to share it is
gonna do it cuz like switch just because
it felt like I don't I have no idea how
that plays handheld but like it just
seemed like an easier way to play this
game but maybe I don't know jeez so I
have everything about Dark Souls is
every NPC ends with an evil laugh that's
great it's good it's good stuff
chain backstabs sad face as where's yeah
you never know there's there still gonna
be day one patches and things like that
that's the thing the version we're
playing does not have to do pageants
yeah
okay so we're going back down here I
need to get
as turtle but Mon says we all play the
same Dark Souls games over and over
anyways the reverb multiplayer
experience is almost a new game in its
own right for some of us so yeah that's
that's kinda how I feel especially cuz I
played when I first played Dark Souls it
was on the PC but I played a couple of
years after it already been out so I
didn't really get good online experience
uh-huh
Ben wants you to try out that UI scaling
oh sure yeah
what's up goob Toby Suffern Suffern n
says what do you think about Cod maybe
it's a better one I don't know I'll
probably play Cod I mean cod looks like
more Cod so if you like cod I guess it's
good I'm curious how the battle royale
stuff will work or like what it'll look
like I think they still haven't
confirmed like how many players and all
that stuff in one match but you know
we'll see okay this scaling is near
scaling snoo yeah what else is new in
this version ask Bob Jones oh the
network stuff so can't do anything right
now but you can set they aim they
include all the network stuff from Dark
Souls 3 all that kind of stuff better
frame rate a better frame rate yeah run
since 60 the whole way through
regardless of ps4 or ps4 problem oh nice
so I'm I'm playing on a regular by the
way oh right really yes for some reason
it's alright because we got our debugger
debug is a reference which I will try to
see if we can fix that okay yeah
probably probably need to yeah let's do
a dance you and me let's dance come on
come on you use your rapier Oh or give
us a backstab or free hits I like it the
old hit them through the wall never gets
old
that was the thing they eventually fixed
in later ones so I'm out here had this
issue but again to dark quarters yeah
yeah it hits it yeah but now it kind of
bounces off right a little bit sometimes
sometimes it's weird it's um it's in
certain circumstances it'll clip a
little bit but like for the most part
I've had it where like I'm like oh I got
this guy and then I'm like dings off the
wall and I'm like oh sheesh
so it was wayward I'm not shocked by
that actually I need to get a key are
you happy that bf5 is world war two I
know I never played battlefield really
always play Cod streaky I don't that
might be the one I need you're here I
gotta go with what your what do you
think cuz I have no idea what areas are
you not allowed to go to I can pull up
Annie I can't go underneath the so I
can't I can't go to the catacombs early
I can't go to good I can't go to the
catacombs early I can't go to New Londo
ruins early I can't go underneath I
can't go past the tight night demon to
the dark roots garden oh so there you go
he nailed all of them we can go to
Blighttown if we I can part of like
where we're gonna try to get to except
as John we've mentioned even for himself
it's like he played the game a certain
way and it's kind of weird to try to go
like superlinear yeah I can't go to the
Basin either where Havel is I can't go
there so like all the fixes like using
like the master key to like shortcut I
can't do any of that I can't skip the
Capra demon I can't skip the keeping
dragon yeah yeah um we can't since we
can't use shortcuts he can't go straight
to Plato nyet that is correct yeah I am
gonna head to not sure about that one
Toby fortunately but he asked what the
last one about Kyle what do you think
about the rumor that there will only be
a season pass for zombies don't know I
don't know hard to say
also it's a rumor so I don't know it's
pretty cool that there's so many on fire
here zombie like maps
is this on ps4 yes it is just a normal
one because we're playing on a debug
because that's how we got the like I I
can't go past it but I could try
fighting it we can save that for later
or whenever it's right here so right now
a real quick one all right it's a it's a
little like psy.d sidewalk yeah it's not
is it like really trying to think of
like someone that's like similar in Dark
Souls 3 like when you go down to like
the prison and you fight that like frost
night for the first time kind of like
that that's kind of like that like a
harder version of like a pretty much
takes I don't know you tell me how much
how much do you like your axe I don't
know Cassie I don't everyone that says
caught is dead I don't I don't think you
guys realize that they just continue to
sell a lot of that game despite people
saying it's dead people saying it's like
people say Madden's dead but they
continue to sell that game well you know
what I mean
so there's a reason they can make one a
year right right but I'm gonna the
regular enemy you just pretty strong at
this point of the game oh okay yeah
totally so let's create the spear here I
want that reach huh
yeah you'll poke I like it pretty good I
think like there's a lot more um like
corridors in this game than I remember
you're seeing in other ones I guess so
the spear or anything that you can poke
with seems like a good option
you guys get you the blood-borne 2
Easter egg in this remastered no
controlling because I feel like I would
have heard that's pretty good though
ok let's see oh man it was the best
we're playing one of those like trivia
type game or maybe not trivia
you ever play heads up no it's it's like
this game where you know like you have
the word and you have information but
you can't say what the word is so you're
trying to get people to guess it right
and the word was Cthulhu and I really
wanted to be like blood-borne there's
like Lovecraftian like please somebody
in this room none of them we're going
but none of them were gamers so like
even if I said blood-borne they would
have never understood tentacle monster
type thing I'm definitely not gonna do
that America sniper sorry hello alright
so this boy here Lord does he stay on
the ground though oh he's got okay he's
only got one leg no problem stone okay
okay at least he only does two strikes
probably look at that Gary that spoke
tail I did nothing 27 tickling him oh
yeah
so you can just run past him to that
area but I cannot go there so we will
fight him see if we can get him excuse
me sir
hi I like to poke your tail I can't even
see okay hold on only look at my screen
what
oh I'm good don't worry don't don't
worry I'm trying to look at how much
damage you've actually done it's not a
lot let's just say that it's like a
finger axe would it did more Oh probably
I don't think so I don't you should do
what you feel is right in your heart
which is to slowly poke this guy to
death yeah we'll get there okay with
that eventually chat oh no you're doing
pretty good damage actually now these
guys are like normal enemies you
encounter way late in the game they just
grow one of these early on you it's like
a fun little like screw you from the
death good these guys are great though
because they dropped titanite shards
which is this game like dartsville I
think so maybe a little dark souls's
artists those games I will say okay good
good oh you're stuck on that little calm
I don't like that the game I for some
reason I thought was gonna come out
sooner but I don't think there's a date
on it yet is code Bane he'd do a three
hit combo yeah oh yeah that's alright
that's what you want to clip you on
these stairs so you're saying he's like
wart
it's like most bosses oh that's that's
fair
demon souls is the dark souls of Dark
Souls games I mean yes I mean that is
where it originated that is actually a
game that I would like a remaster elf or
even a remake like proper I'd like to
see something yeah I mean like part of
it was I think people were speculating
that it might have been Demon Souls
right before or what's that one is it uh
sorry if I butchered is it blue point
exactly dew point right and they're
working on some what like remake right
that is like onion like what they have
not announced what it is people are
speculating it said that is actually was
my theory as well perhaps Demon Souls
play I mean Sony's the one who owns the
rights to that so they can do it
okay close
well whittling him down and we're
getting them yeah or gianluca's I'm
really here just kind of watching
Abdullah's excited oh but smash i
abdullah says I'm so excited for cocaine
yeah I'm curious I am curious to see how
it plays out especially with the whole
companion thing I feel like it makes the
game a little bit easier but we'll see
you never know I just feel like when the
boss has to like you know deters or
defers attention to like another AI kind
of frees you up to do whatever you want
which is part of what makes these games
great is like you're kind of duel with
the boss and being afraid at all times
whereas with it with a kind of
a partner so to speak or co-op AI kind
of gives you some time to breathe but I
guess I did that in Worcester hunter in
a way because the cat can sometimes draw
aggro okay okay right in the ABS oh god
I'm got him there you go huh son
we did it we did it we got demon
titanite all right I can't go there can
i order that nice view turn around
which still boggles both of our minds
because it's like the games been out
seven years for a while then come on
yeah it's not weird wonder if some day
one stuff needs to fix some of that
stuff you never know maybe that's what
it is
I don't know Shrek boss in this game now
now you can bought a shrek boss let's
see he says I think the commands are
optional okay in which case that's kind
of cool if it's just optional then you
got a demon titanite everything like
that I am I think at least if I read
that correctly is it 1 over plus 5
praise the Sun correct Andy do I have
that
this one I always like I never pract
ever did I never got the art of this
down well it always looked bad help me -
I'm bosses I would always try to like on
game play like oh yeah I'm gonna do an
emo and it just looks worse because I'm
pulling up all this UI yeah I have like
are you not entertained so no changes
besides the one buyer bonfire and
graphic FPS networks actually a couple
of changes as well there is another
bonfire they added to the in the
catacombs there is the secret blacksmith
I forget his name but they added a
bonfire there that you can fast travel
to because it was always a real pain to
get to that guy if you wanted to like
get some special stuff from him so they
added that which is really cool
they've also man there was a couple
other things I want to say they tweaks
but I don't remember offhand all right I
got an email like a while ago where they
were like breaking that down alright
where are we headed to now we're gonna
head back to Sochi with a bow a bow tie
to your ass travel to any case that's
not a thing got him that's the other
thing you forget when you it's been a
while is that you're like all right I
can't fast travel
all right any any interesting question
really I mean there's been some comments
Abdulla things Dark Souls 1 on PC what
dsfix looks better to be honest I mean
it's hard to compete with PC when a
sheriff I'm talking console stuff that
was good that was yeah excellent this
guy yeah this would be a weird
experience for me I mean I'm just not
used to so many shielded dudes right
yeah you can they can kick dodge yep
joyeux this Aaron says here we go again
PC beggars talking and crap about this
game I mean they're entitled to your
opinion I mean like part of that is yeah
there's gonna be some PC elitism when
they compared to consoles I think it's
just like that's just part but it but it
is fair I mean to some degree like some
of that stuff looks better it's then
that's just that right sure but I think
at the end of the day it's like say your
piece about it and then just don't buy
it no I think um people tend to like
talking circles a lot where they just
keep harping on it and harping on it and
it's like hey man you can have your
opinion you can you can say it let's we
get it gadget Mike 21 says how do you
think this game has aged since 2011
I think it's aged very well in my
opinion actually yeah I think it's aged
very well oh hello one one little last
poke there got him you probably got an
item from that note assumed earlier
that's like I think this game still has
some of my favorite level design in the
whole series they're kind of the
interconnectivity of it all it's really
really good close real close there don't
lose I don't know what would have been
yeah if it would have mattered okay well
there's yes SEMA this is 60fps right yes
okay nice you can't block forever
alright yeah as Luis Jimenez says even
if it does look better it's well worth
of performance improvements and network
updates yeah I mean someone had
mentioned that earlier as well that you
know just getting the the the kind of
like network I went I don't know if
they're upgrades but like getting that
back is already like kind of like a big
deal for the people that play the game
quite a bit also say like you know game
looks just as good or if you know better
with dsfix there's still the fact that
you need the dsfix on the pc version to
like get it to run good so there's
something to be said about like hey
there's a version of this game that
actually just kind of like runs good on
PC without mod support yeah you know you
could argue like they should have had
that in the beginning or they should
have passed it and I'll agree with that
but it's like hey at least there's
finally like a version on PC that you
could just play out of the box and it
runs good Hanzo and Genji means it's
Dark Souls remastered tomorrow you'll
have your day when overwatch anniversary
happens yes ok
okay there's a black man up there I'm
not gonna bother with that
what's up PCG how you doing so this is
that new bonfire okay let's see my
problem one back step at a time just
kidding the old lead them away it's not
$50 Mike it's actually 40 come on guys
oh yeah you buy whatever game at
whatever price you want I'm being very
cautious here that's fair
is there any new content there's too
many room Astor's nowadays says portal
player well I think what it is is I
think that as okay it's not just a
gaming industry okay
hello there's my boy oh you're getting
the lid on fire oh come on yeah that's
fine there yes hello it's not just the
gaming industry it's oh it's $49.99
Canada fair okay it's not the gaming
industry not just they gave me a mystery
anymore it's the movie industry as well
a lot of going back to nostalgia a lot
of like I mean [ __ ] there's a predator
movie huh and it's like why I know why
it does that to me doesn't mean look
good but no terrible but you know I
think part of it that's cool is for the
people that didn't experience it
they got to experience it right and for
some of the people and for some of the
people that please
oh nice so for the people that have
played it a bunch it you know it's cool
to kind of like come back and play what
did you need the key for I need the key
to get in I'm pretty sure that's the
door I need Chad how do we get that key
guys tell me how to get to the lower
undead burg because I normally take a
different route don't you can't tame a
boy well is there a way you could take
the route off screen and then get to
this no it's long enough that that would
be okay let me see undead burg lower
undead burg I'm just trying to remember
what I think that's the door
and I'm trying to remember don't
[ __ ] us it's not nostalgia it's just
easy money for not a lot of work I mean
the good nostalgia has to be there for
you to even want to spend the money
that's right it's like they're using
nostalgia to trying to get that easy
money is what we're saying
yeah I didn't use that word but there
you go same thing you need to have that
nostalgia for people to even buy it to
want to buy it right it doesn't matte
remastering it to get more money doesn't
work just because it's like oh okay
no work we're gonna make a lot of money
I mean people complain about this and
I'm saying you can't complain about it
you shouldn't but it's like you know the
reason they do this is because people
will buy it and it works so it's like
hey man speak with you speak with your
money do you need the basement key that
what it is yes that is but where do I
get the basement key let's take a look
now I remember I was thinking what's the
done found in the undead parish undead
parish opens the door to lower undead
burg swears in the end because I was
just at the parish okay I'm gonna get
roasted by this it's can be found in a
corpse down the stairs from the church
in undead parish near the lever that
opens the portcullis back to the area
with the faying for which we're not
going to open it just there
roasty-toasty
was done that's fine actually I won't
need you because not bad rip one only
because we didn't have the key I'm not
gonna do it now also because I would
just take forever but you can get
underneath the bridge and if you just
shoot the dragon's tail for like I don't
know forever ten minutes with a bow
you'll eventually cut it off and you get
yourself a great sword oh okay so that's
the lever wasn't it they're talking
about this little anyway so it's
somewhere I must have just ran past it
then also wait definitely did I never
open that door I don't know I don't know
you you may or may not have the answer
to this but apparently female Adams s
and do weapons degrade faster because of
fps like what happened in ds2 scholar
the person now okay I have not noticed
any difference in weapon
I think they eventually fix that was an
issue no ia but I've noticed that okay
okay well these guys again yeah that's
right that dragon had his way with us
oh that's fine that's why still gain
life no problem I forgot sorry his his
name was portal or at least had portal
in it was saying that unfortunately the
switch is now the remaster machine yeah
I I will say the thing that does
moderately upset me a bit but I guess
it's just a reality is just seeing some
of the bigger name titles that have come
out like a while ago that but that are
coming to switch that are like $60 games
and I'm like uh and they're not
necessarily better experiences and it's
just like they should be like 40 you
know like a couple of them have been 40
like Skyrim was 40 I think but doom was
like 60 I think it's the other way
around
no I'm pretty sure doom was 60 and
Skyrim Skyrim remastered let's find out
was it remastered am I saying that right
Skyrim special edition on switch special
edition okay
Skyrim switch is oh you're right because
he was 16 so how much was dude I think
that was the $40 one no it was it was at
some point 50 yeah it was 40 bucks there
was something that was 40 Eldar for Dark
Souls is gonna be 40 was it le noir was
that the one no there's no way that
could have been 60 I mmm 101 was 40 I
just don't remember what the Wolfenstein
was also I think 60 on switch someone in
chat will remind me probably the boys I
agree that that should
come on beep Kumar says I'd rather play
blood-borne again to be honest I'd love
to play blah I can and some I don't even
I don't even need it to be updated I'll
play it again I guess but I would love I
don't need a full like remaster I just
want a pro patch that makes it so it
doesn't run at like 15 frames a second
that's cool as you tried the like what
was it be like not enhanced it wasn't
really that watch out wasn't really that
good right it like shaped a couple but
it wasn't like a significant improvement
that you want cuz it's not like a proper
patch it's just sort of taking an
advantage of the increased like you know
CPU and GPU to kind of naturally the way
like the X but no no I did come here
that's but I'm supposed to have barely
found the key here yeah I'm here okay it
might be backwards where that corpse
let's find out yeah it might be that one
he says nearly it said excuse me
it said near the lever yeah or leave it
anyway sorry guys no we're good
not even that we're on course we killed
that one guy this is good I'm just happy
to play more Dark Souls for any reason
that's fair and one says if you haven't
played it you should probably play I'm
guessing that's the blood-borne there's
my guess one of my favorite games is
generally I can't make it past the first
boss on blood-borne elbow I'm much
better at Dark Souls for some reason
it's a fast yeah it's definitely risk
with more risky reward type play but
yeah cuz you know what it's it's it
could be that maybe so you know you're
just used to blocking a lot whereas you
can't really block it you pretty much
can't block in that game until like way
like until you get to what old hunters
where you actually get a proper shield
and even then and that's even then you
don't want to block really did you get
the key sorry I'm not seen it yet okay
cool nice
[Music]
let's go underneath the the bridge yeah
I want to avoid the dragon although I do
have to fight these rats down here and
some Brants apparently Bob's telling me
Street Fighter collection is forming on
switch which is good these rats suck as
a and there is an area I could go to get
me some healing stuff with poison fire I
actually can't go in there right now
which kind of sucks cuz the next year
we're gonna go do is all boys all poison
enemies yeah but I can't go to that area
okay yep that's all right anyway let's
creep over here oh hello this is good
this is good just keep going yeah see
here oh okay you didn't do it you didn't
do the old one war on accident play
where you swing too much and fly off the
ledge yeah can you please do a history
of souls games episodes I love those I
would assume I love those as in history
of because that John Luke does do
history uggs it's been on my mind i I
thought about it for this remaster and
there was just no way I could do that in
time but it is something I thought about
somebody else in the office
Alessandro asked me if I was
here yeah I can see myself doing one it
just won't have like a specific reason
unless he had the gate we got the key
unless we hear about shadows night twice
at e3 and that ends up being a Souls
type of game I still think that's ten
shoes yeah I don't think it's gonna be
full on souls I bet there will be some
souls influenced for sure yeah I could
see that made it no problem all right
mistake with blood-borne by using blood
vials Ohio Sun seems fine
like considering you're gonna like fight
more often I feel like it makes sense to
kind of have that's what a circle is
whatever your sprint is it's not the
same I don't I don't know I know is but
I do not remember
Rockman was not a huge you tried playing
blood-borne again more recently but he
wasn't a fan of the speed of blood-borne
and Dark Souls 3 yeah Dark Souls 3 is
definitely more of like a hybrid it's
definitely faster hybrid which I like
actually too so I don't know personally
okay farming four vials is bad really
ever have to farm though I could always
buy fine hello there okay this is
actually good this is a shortcut I
unlocked
I think is full of full of shortcuts all
the time it's just a matter of the the
other shortcuts were like specific areas
Oh gotcha gotcha this is just a shortcut
leading back they should have just they
should have just have estes only and no
healing items
I don't know I thought it was fine to me
I was fine I mean it's more blood-borne
is more of a spiritual successor to
Demon Souls and it is and you had like a
bunch of those little feeling like you
had all those type of similar healing
mechanics right
roughly yeah oh yeah Adam moon grass
dream I've never played the game two
cushions
what can this game be compared to and
would you recommend this game to people
who have not played this I'd compare it
to a Dark Soul for comparison know if
demon's soul if you compare it to demon
some very good also I'm getting
bombarded words anyway it's called the
stream that's what happened
we're gonna go down Alberto I would say
Hawaii we're gonna hate this because
they put that barren okay you didn't
it's like a kind of hard action game
tactical obviously and pretty
unforgiving in some cases in the sense
that like if you die you lose all the
like souls you you just got which you
more or less have to like you know
accrue as you kill monsters and in order
to get those you know souls back
essentially you have to go back to where
you died and if you die again you just
lose all that which means you lose
progress etc etc which is frustrating
you know yes era can be frustrating so
if you're not into frustrating games I
would say this one might not be for you
but if you have patience and you're
maybe a little bit of a masochist
because I feel like you have to be a
little bit just a little bit to want to
continue playing these games
remember this guy at all
it's locked Oh apparently bitter I says
ds1 is different from sliding down
ladders just press circle alone without
pressing down on the analog hope you
read this okay
well we read it in time for next time
exactly
so 2019 is the 10th anniversary of demon
souls Asterix praise to Blue Point get
licked ripped - like a lame way to die
now someone else is saying bill will tap
next I'm gonna go with the other guy
well we'll try both I think you should
do the circle one first if you're gonna
do one just because I feel like that one
seems more legitimate who knows both
could get us killed and it'll be fine
then I can blame chat SS solved all
healing item issues yeah I don't know
see the thing is custom for me I since I
didn't play the Dark Souls games before
I just never had in my head what was
right or wrong or whatever I don't know
I always thought the viola sting was
fine and I think miles at least for the
people that are like trying to get into
the series it gives them more of a
leeway or you know accessibility so to
speak sure but I don't know maybe as a
purist it's I could see why you feel the
way you do hey but if you're a purist
pyrius then you'd play demon souls which
have the craftsmen himself it's all
about you perspective
apparently there's a 20th anniversary
for tenchu at some point I don't know
when that is
yeah Maxwell shed also to Alberto maybe
consider playing blood-borne
instead of this room master because it's
more modern and also it's a brilliant
yeah I mean this game you see players do
get a discount if you have the like
prepare to die edition like at Follies
half off so I think you'll pay 20 bucks
for it which is admittedly I mean either
than other Steam games were like
Bioshock when they did those remasters
you just got it for free so I'll agree
there's a precedent for getting it
better that like you can kind of Scott
your knows that but it's something at
least yeah
CBB 88 Christian says not gonna lie the
bonfire effects in the remaster are
pretty sweet I think it's a pretty sweet
so yeah there are better fire effects
there's better effects for like the like
when there's an item on somebody like
that kind of stuff so there they have
done some improvements but I can also
understand certain people being like oh
like this doesn't look better the
lighting looks too different I don't
think it's the case where I think there
been summary masters where they like
change it in a way that feels like it
compromises the original like vision of
the game and so far I haven't noticed
anything of that level like there's
always minor things in it but I don't
think there's a compromise
I'll force-feed you says blood-borne is
a better overall game they're all worth
a playthrough though besides to to gets
the short end I guess - gets a bad rap I
don't think T's as bad as people make it
out to be but of the of all of that said
I do personally think it's the weakest
and I have a lot of problems with it but
I do think it gets a bad rap you need
the mask so you need the master key to
get some of the earlier areas unlocked
but to do what we're doing we're fine
yeah what we're doing is fine and also I
was specifically told I could I could
have grabbed the master key but I
couldn't use it these guys a little
faster changes the pace of combat here
they try and do some oh he drinks flasks
oh yeah they do that a lot in this one I
forgot like they don't want to do that
as much in there yeah and the other ones
it's really like other like hunters or
you know like now you'll have like an
omen enemies to it okay I was like that
guy couldn't the other guy kind of died
too though so that was just a rag doll
of one of the okay Wow
Abdullah Allen Allen a Crim says that I
might buy a switch just for this
that's pretty I'm really curious how
that version is gonna play I was gonna
be 30 frames a second but if it's the
solid 30 frames a second I think that is
absolutely doable especially considering
you know like Dark Souls 3 was you know
like 30 frames and the original Dark
Souls on Xbox 360 was like sub 30 mmm
gur bought one one nine some of these
areas they look pretty ugly yeah a
little bit it's about my least favorite
areas visually there's some later areas
though that are really
okay best of moments this seems a lot
better with graphics in the stress test
did it change well we have like an early
review version that's what we're playing
right now we're also on a debug just ps4
not a pro-rata Pro the only difference
is is to be between the two is the
ability to play in 4k there's no
difference to framerate or anything I
mean what have you noticed does this
look better to you than the stress test
or roughly the same the same yeah that's
what the spear is good for a little
fewer eclipses no good here oh that's
silly it literally was touching a shield
I think there's a shortcut general
Grievous's people are complaining but
come on man it's Dark Souls on next-gen
oh hello well played well please I
should have expected that well at least
you didn't get attacked from behind
there yeah there's that boss boy little
boss boy I hate him are you looking for
a shortcut
uh yeah hole did they do the whole like
invisible wall stuff and this one oh
yeah the thief gear look at that
me likey that's a good one if I want to
get my roll on get your roll on all
right what's the plan here John Luke
four flasks yeah or maybe like three
really yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna use the
staircase a lot is my alright Capra
demon here we go
you'll see I've already backed myself
into a
stupid two dogs okay let's try and get
this wheel gone
okay haha stairs yes duck okay yep yep
you got the old triple team there yeah
yeah he's gotta believe in you he
becomes just a regular enemy later in
the game
oh really yeah they just start throwing
at you later okay get ready boys
prediction death yeah you predict it
pretty well there oh yeah run up you
want oh we got it we got it don't want
to guess so so you got to fight all that
stuff again just yeah if I remember I
kind of like would just cheese it and
run through and yeah yeah but still
that's like that's a lot to run through
it's a couple of bosses in this game to
have a pretty long like one time up to
the boss this is the most [ __ ] boss
in the game says duck s Duck Sauce not
lady I remember him probably giving me
one of those troubles boss next to like
I don't know like some of the really
tough ones like Manas gave me a lot of
trouble I remember yeah I mean this one
again it's like one of those things
that's annoying just because of the
other little guys that are bothering you
and it's like how do we quickly dispense
of these dogs so that we can just
actually deal with the demon himself
yeah
and he's an optional boss you can't
ignore him if you use the master key
but we cannot there's always another way
not on this stream Johnny Rogers we only
know one way
all right well we're gonna have 4's this
alright let's try and do a speed run
here see if we can make speed run I'm
gonna say how many attempts you thank
you I think you're gonna kill him I just
I appreciate that
I just don't know how many tries it's
gonna take I say five or less what do
you think chat no oh JK and then my yep
JK did not hit x2 did I did I just got
grabbed okay this doesn't count as a
death by the way he didn't actually
fight the boss so you can get grabbed
before you go in as a nation
[Music]
hmm I was hoping to get to the to the
depths but I think you got it don't sell
yourself short old-timer Paris is
fighting the Capra demon it's like
trying to bullfight in a cupboard yeah
the camera is the real it's like the
environment is the real reason it sucks
is because you you got this tight space
you got the camera and then they got
those two other dogs like it's
everything's against you in that fight
cinders Z says I wonder if John wick is
here the Baba Yaga is not here
the boogeyman is not here until he might
show up to help John Luke kill the Capra
demon but we'll see how that be green
tape brings bad luck confirms Wow come
on
I hosik our ho sec says at least 10 do
they know about the role 'button what's
a role you mean this is this game worth
doing redoing all the achievements
that's up to you I feel like sweet
chivos stopping by okay so that didn't
go well last time might need to do a
little bit of a slower run kills the dog
kill the dog burn for the stairs play
catch yeah yep I mean yeah you want to
kill the dogs and then you want to
essentially I think the staircase I mean
your plan the first time I think was
correct it was just like one of those
like bad luck situations of how you fell
and then getting immediately just
surrounded so that's the biggest problem
with that boss is even if you know what
to do you can just kind of get a Oren
Jesus we need Oh Harry
yeah kit parried oh I'm safe well he did
just Harry you I'm also terrible at
Harry's in this game so I never used
them
it's a paries is like a thing I like to
do my second playthrough it's just learn
I've never bothered to learn it I only
have probably should Chris B says eight
point four attempts no more no less
okay okay I don't remember this grab at
all
well it surprised you every day you
learn something new
Oh someone said its new is that really
new grabbed from behind remember I
remember that okay oh that's not good I
could actually no I can't ever mind what
I was gonna say I could dangle Melvin
has no faith in fire says you won't I
won't be able to beat him I think you
all oh this is this is not so great oh
oh now you can back out though can you
close the door and then run for the try
it
clover in for the day there's stuck
right now oh this is great yeah let's do
it yeah I think he's still stuck yeah
yeah you're good
yes I don't want to roll that up
I just can't cuz I mean it sounds it
looked like you were gonna take damage
from that no matter what right Oh
followed you there excuse me sir how did
you he slashed you as I think you're
gonna have to roll that first one yeah
he's about to get lit up by the
cafeteria yeah sick camp position yeah
right okay so my role is great because
of the the the weight yeah the weight
percentage oh [ __ ] this will be funny
good she's I'm on the stairs we're
trying to cheese him on the stairs a
little bit but you know just use a
shortcut from Firelink okay are you
allowed to do that lol only five SS go
for ten guys you'll make things a lot
shortcut from finally cuz you're
referring to I don't know that was from
NASA's I don't think I can use that one
we try this role this is this person
here's a protip to this guy put your
shield down and fight one at a time what
do you mean don't know is this a version
that will come out there's gonna be a
day one patch but we are on like a like
review build of the game there's full
game just lacks the day one patch
death is coming it already happened
turtle little turtle as much as we need
to
that's the other thing if I want one
sleep later I will have to buy this kind
of drop some equipment load I did that
you're too heavy
I don't know this is just I'm reading
chat dude you don't don't listen to me
if you fix it you fix no sure I was just
trying to look at my well level are you
21 I might be a little over then wait
because I think you want to get some 25%
I forego pantsless watch out oh boy
hello pantsless shirtless
I'm leaving the stream we're gonna be
here all day you don't know that I have
go to Firelink in all caps of what does
that mean you'll have to remind me I'm
sorry I've the UH the lower undead burg
it's like the one I remember the least
about cuz I used to skip it all the time
so I there is another shortcut from
Firelink please man people are not happy
about the spear they don't like my
spirit they're not they're not about
then I've out it a pair what would they
prefer I don't know I'm just reading
chat man I like the school barbecue how
much will this cost is $39.99 upgrade
the fireplace renovate the loft repaint
the kid's room sure the fireplace remove
the armor use two hands don't target the
boss role for your life gather basic
meth he does not play game you beat the
game before yeah relax everyone plays
differently just because you play one
way doesn't mean that he has to play it
the same way you do most people
Rockman Bionic says Spears legit
aqueducts go right this is remastered
I'm doing some rolls I'm doing some roll
practice boom Nasus I'm trying we got
delayed you got to remember that in
front of the boss room turn right okay
says Collin thank you that rings a bell
because I do remember there being like
somewhat of a faster way I just guess we
don't like you in all caps guys well
then you can just leave oh yeah then
please leave if you're not you're not
feeling it the door is that way
shortcut to fire link not from fire line
we got a victor thank you everyone's
like the funny thing is we're not even
at the door for them to be upset yeah
you know what I mean it's just the door
man I've never played it so I'll be
upfront about that I've only played
blood-borne and Dark Souls 3 beat both
though so that's the whatever
credibility that has also beat neo but I
don't know how where people rank Neos
toughness it was pretty tough first time
where it's got the drake sword then yes
yes thanks Fred pretty hard candy $39.99
for me master really yeah always
I knew always look around the corner oh
you gots to do that come on oh these
guys are throwing [ __ ] all the time
powers things that you're not gonna make
it without your shield we'll see I'm
kinda using my shield most of the run so
it's like easier to it's what you're
used to
why exactly is the gaping dragon
optional if you use the back entrance
and then my chat freakin yes dippin
dragon is totally optional however to
unlock the shortcuts do you skip it is
something I cannot do or not to do that
straight sword sorry I'm trying to like
wow there's a lot more chat than I
thought
apparently we have to play exactly the
way Steve wants us to
okay got it no wonder and it makes sense
now thanks Nick
appreciate it Nick em just cuz we play
well doesn't mean he has to you guys you
guys stop everyone's a critic
on the internet it's really easy to
judge when you're not oh yes aha oh dude
sir
another minor thing with this version
that we'll be fixing the day one patch
is NPC voices are a bit lower something
seem a little bit lowered oh yeah I
could turn it up just the general volume
that's all yeah that's just part of this
build yeah that's gonna be only spear I
agree with is orange tines says psycho
15 once time spirit it's pretty good
okay so I can buy some purple Moss if I
need you from this dude otherwise let's
go this way I'm gonna stay and roast you
alright that's fair but if you get out
of hand I'm gonna get rid of you just so
you know I mean some criticisms fine but
you know you know you don't have to be
over the top of it although I feel like
by saying that I've now Tetum up to
probably do that so probably it's
alright we I can always do the old
timeout or something okay so yeah this
is a I don't know if it's it's probably
a little bit longer to go this way to do
this path there's a lot of time I go to
the latest stuff it will get me to fire
link which will get me Birkett say it's
like kind of a shortcut like it's
arguably probably would take longer
maybe but I'm gonna fight less enemies
most difficult enemies and I will get
the boost of the Firelink shrine which
will get me 10 flash so it's it's worth
it thank you good reminder there for
reminding me but I knew there was in my
head I was
yeah there's no discount on console that
I know not like PC oh he's still doing
flips do a barrel roll you want some too
is it fun so far this is weird for me
not seeing this but only seeing this in
3 what Firelink yeah yeah man it's like
a different version if I'm like oh I
also cannot go do the thing with the
Raven in this build quoth the Raven well
I mean you can do it again but now can't
do that yet anyway so now I have a good
10 flasks which is great so let's try
this the problem with the fight so far
those I just even added time to use any
flasks that's true people are saying
this is faster ok nice it probably is
please trust this is faster okay don't
worry we trust we trust we trust just
like how you guys got us here so not all
of Chad is here to antagonize take us
out
I do appreciate all the tips though guys
it does help us obviously yeah
appreciate it
dust thou have no humanity oh I do
I could have popped him another thing
they've added in this one that's nice is
when you can now when you use an item
like this you can actually pick the
quant quantity nice which they add in
like two long words before you'd have to
do like one at a time out of that
someone was telling me to use your
humanity to upgrade your bonfire yes
what's wrong with the Raven nothing
wrong with the Raven we're just not
allowed to show it we're just not a lot
we're not allowed to show it it's one of
those word restrictions how much do you
blink
well not Blaine cuz he's missing the
word he probably meant to say get but
he's typing a terrible sentence to me
how much do you get from band I pay you
for the stream oh nothing absolutely
nothing yeah people say that all the
time and it's like man I wish I was
getting paid I know right I'm sorry I'd
love to get some money for doing this we
get to say whatever we want
good bad
do you know if there's a platinum trophy
for this one
I do not know someone says don't waste
the humanity I'll suture missed Alger's
kicking in for Rainier mmm okay so
that's a weird restriction yeah there's
a lot of weird restricted to being
honest like he's not allowed to use
shortcuts either which is like certain
short measured I can't go to the darker
base and I can't fight the optional boss
there because that was actually been
kind of a cool and I would have maybe
done instead if I could have anyway here
at the foot boss great
his roll this one oh you could actually
didn't do the leaking attack it's good
this is good haha we found a lift
oh you're still alive
and then the okay you can you cheese it
from that little lip that little sewer
hole you were stuck on top you realize
that right yes what I'm hoping is the
ideal situation is I get him down there
I get up there and I should do a like a
top word grant says my friend did
nothing but criticize me when I did play
his way just keep doing you I think it's
basically what you said thank you
especially this game just because
there's so many builds or so many paths
you can take for so many like shortcuts
and like just like how many do you
they're saying shield down to regen
faster I mean this is how he wants yeah
I know the show regions like he just let
it be I was like are they using the
spear for memes or they just serious I
know we're serious I just like you know
I can switch the axe I think you should
just use whatever you want to be honest
whatever you think will give you the
best success rate that's how I look at
it like if anything I'm like the
stubborn one so like I usually just like
keep throwing my head at the wall with
whatever I'm using because I'm just like
no I'm gonna do it my way and I don't
really care I've been like that so it's
like yeah that's whatever typically I
like playing these games with the katana
which I guess I could actually go get if
I go kill that shopkeeper the axe also
sucks
that's Pigman mister it does I don't
like using next kill the dog first we
know we're definitely trying to wear the
dog I'm aware that I should kill the
dogs we're definitely trying to kill the
dog sirs does not the issue
Oh which chat are they reading where I'm
reading both which can you do we got
both try the broken straight sir for the
walls I like that I go with no I'm
trying to give him the best success
right here Blighttown is meant to be
played at 9 to 15 fps the true the true
dark souls experience playing blade town
at sub 10 frames a second YouTube really
likes back seating of course
okay I want to get yeah yeah just leave
me oh geez stupid I hate it's fine it's
fine this is this is good that was not
worth it though
haha suck it you can't reach us demon
and watch other oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's the strategy okay I got him
cool yeah you you got one more Doge
though to deal with here why do ya oh no
no maybe you didn't get him my bad I
thought you I thought you backstabbed
lay boss
yeah we're fine
fire biomes for the win oh I hate when
he does that oh I that's fine plenty of
flasks those extra five we're gonna come
in handy
yeah man these are those those strats
you're using on that other guy like way
from like back in the day gets ter
cheesed yep do it oh this is a little
bit of predicament Oh fine you're not
doing the big whining oh man I really
can't wait to be like yeah spear guys
[Music]
oh I need to get back to these new
messages classic stair glitch
oh yeah how do you like that roll guys
top-notch roll right there might have
been a panic but I'm gonna go with it
was top notch no plan oh right here BAM
got sup spear life baby how many times
in your life you only bottom like less
than five all right
right I think well I depends are we
counting the ones where you ran to him
are we just counting the ones where you
actually fought him I'm pretty sure it
was five or less actual boss attempts
and that's the spear all right the power
of the sphere oh I don't want to hear it
where's the depths guys I need help now
after I threw it back at you now I need
help I can look it up
alright somewhere around here yeah we
work we work this [ __ ] out of that shoot
my dare wait wait you got it you gotta
be able you gotta be willing to do some
things in your life to get by some
bosses if it's in the game let's see
what are you looking for the depths I
think it's I think it's the story let's
see GG easy clap hook it up boom sweet
get good scrubs oh we got good luff
steam a suspiro P confirmed I don't know
about that but at least we killed him
with the boss
you know IRA with the spear with the
ball on the boss okay
I hate the dance hello this randomly
dark people flanking you and you don't
get one you don't get one of those cool
little lanterns that uh you get on plug
warned huh no turn that guy on they
don't have the now the true test to the
mice and butchers Oh yep the butchers
yep Z butcha and the mice the dumb mice
okay now get cursed this is Chris kr ya
that you can get cursed here sucks
it's alright good thing we got those
extra flasks we got seven we have way
more than we had before
mmm-hmm don't forget the cursing frogs
yeah big man
anslee who says I mean you can pretty
much make any weapon work if you have a
good knowledge yeah but you say that now
but like you know a half of chat with
likes fear meme spirit it's like yeah
okay so if we're recognizing that you
can make any weapon work then it's like
let it be we can make a fire torch work
probably you can level up before dying
for serious oh that's actually a good
call but then you just killed all this
stuff I should have I say take on the
butcher just have like a little Club oh
yeah this is great
that's bad for days
yeah I don't think there are torches in
this game yet I know that now Oh random
helper okay mister paper bag here
he looks like a zero for enemy
well Silent Hill maybe such much anxiety
sitting here in the air much anxiety
it's a she by the way oh my bad might be
she is the the butcher Thank You cat
thank you thank you don't one
discriminate I definitely don't somebody
so this area is new to me yes I mean you
can totally like skip this if you want I
didn't know
as mentioned never played this this one
so just go day if you're not sure fair
or it there
I think that's like a fake chest uh it
shouldn't be it believe they don't strip
to sense portraits but I still always
play come on like at least trade alright
thank you for the tip on the Estes we
would be in big trouble right now
without him we're good so the way you
can tell is actually a little chain
right she's painting away the chains
yeah some what was just gonna bitter I
just said you can tell if it's a minute
if you look at the chain I always just
attack and just say screw it that way I
know for sure
despite the fact that there's not a
single mimic in blood-borne I still hit
every chest I came across my first time
playing it because really
not a single one I don't remember there
being a single one and I was like
convinced like they're gonna they're
gonna throw it in at some point
mmm and the Dark Souls 3 just throws a
mimic in like the first area and like
the third chest you come across it just
like I was a big like rock man you could
take a little sip the entire game if you
just don't play it this is true I mean
sure
so these dogs are clearly stronger they
take like three hits
compared to the two from earlier Tim
Tebow's can you roll for me please
there you go there's your one roll is
your role in Dark Souls you don't just
drink the ssds drinks you boy
this game was great I loved it
don't go down before leveling well how
close is the bonfire oh look at that
he's just hanging out Oh cuz then yeah
you're gonna have to kill everything you
just killed right yeah if I die I'll
have to kill everything I'd killed yeah
well we have 20 minutes left that's true
give or take so you know as much as
you're correct Murray leo I feel like
dr. sharm cuz of levels yeah I mean it
makes sense yeah I mean that's what
keeps it interesting right it's like
mixing it up mixing it up now a night
laughs I do remember it can be a little
easy to miss the bonfire so I have the
chat keep an eye out for me on that one
what on this like in this area yeah cuz
I do remember being a little but it's so
dark how do we not see like a big
glowing flame well because it's in like
if I recall was in the doors oh you're
dead potentially okay all right well
this is all or nothing here yes it is or
we we we go with the cowardice way and
legit run and do what Marie leo said to
do from the beginning which is level
before we came down here but you know
what Evers oh you got some you got one
guy with the torch chasing this lead
trouble a closed room oh hey help
please I am stuck in this barrel what
she got for me dude yep yep good nothing
you want me fight these divine blessings
I can use don't know if the trophies the
same said who oh you gonna use the good
stuff good I mean I guess that's fair I
don't really care that clutch uh where
do we clutch I don't feel like we
clutched anything stabbed him instead of
rolling the barrel yeah he a little bit
of it this is stabbing you know like he
was fine with a controlling ultimately
was freed he was freed that's what
matters
butcher come from I'm not sure because
he came through the door I thought or
maybe he's down the hall maybe it's like
down the hall to your right okay he
killed that oh no he did not
oh these those things were there's like
something similar in a me oh these
things that like pissed me off they were
really weak to fire though yes how many
days until their release as leo comes up
the 25th
come on
that's a fair that that's totally fair
jam I mean why wouldn't you do that on
the switch if you had the switch version
she'd probably look
oh hey where did the butcher come from
where did she come from I don't know all
I know she's gone now so that's good boy
so look up the ceiling yeah nothing like
how the game's teach you paranoia
all right we're looking for the shrine
assuming there is one
on our or just not sorry not trying the
bonfire all right
- through the next hall
oh there's a butcher oh yeah oh it's the
back stab there it is
oh this is good this is really good oh
maybe not so much
come on give us the back staff game all
right that works he got him okay I like
we're gonna stack on my head where's the
butcher doing him there oh you got a
sack yep all right can you actually run
past this is that thing you can take all
right you do you I'm reach at switch
Reese release is delayed yes that's
correct
how'd I miss come on feels good yeah
wait not dead close feels good feels
good man
whiff City all right we're good yeah
there are two butchers he killed both
yep we did kill them both we're now
working our way through these
amoeba-like monsters
maybe I'm you was not the right word
sludge what happens there like when it's
freaking out like that I think that's
it's death animation okay so there's not
anything bad that could happen to you
are you GameSpot raelia no no that would
be Edmund Tran Eddie makuu and just
don't there muck that's fair
all right you go one more and then we'll
jump together
slow and steady
he hopes to add some 5:18 that's very
cool
these things were in Anor Londo ds3
right you're thinking of
they're like abyss those things remind
me of uh in blood-borne they had those
like murky brain things yeah they remind
me of the lime was more like the slimes
we fight in Demon Souls with the first
class two phalanx what you fought mmm
that's that was a fun time hey guys
let's not tell him how to beat this boss
oh isn't that the easiest boss yeah it
was that guy before
hey you don't know the trick it's always
tough the first time okay
blonde fire someone oh yeah there's a
giant ass rat right there oh hello
there's some fire below you but I don't
know if that's a bonfire oh look there's
a lot of rats where is that freaking
bonfire chat where's bonfire tell me
where bonfires please so I'm gonna try
and aggro some rats into this corridor
hey anything you could throw on
look at those two running into the wall
oh it's like one of you is someone Oh
got two for one yeah this is good don't
like that I'll take that the key is a
bit further down okay the only fire
wasn't that lock the door okay so we
need the key for that I guess yeah we
got no master key light it's probably a
great axe and humanity right on cue
they're asking for advice yeah of course
why wouldn't I ask for advice that's
part of the Chad interaction come on
come on man throw me a bone here
love you Oh as I say that he comes out
of look at her above the key is right
around the corner sweet where the big
rat is though probably he's just really
big he's a big boy
oh maybe Oh shucks on the other side of
that game
[Music]
that'd be pretty sick if you could
become a flutist I can control all the
rats yeah there you go all right so now
we got to go back to that locked door
don't go that way
thank you chat appreciate what platform
you guys playing on ps4 but just a
normal one because that's our debug you
can heal more than once at a time thank
you
I mean we don't need to right now but
yeah buddy
nah what a surprise one last time really
have you seen any frame drops uh I
haven't there's been some weirdness like
sometimes when you're just like in a
certain like doorway and you happen to
like sort of clip something like earlier
when we're at that boss door for some
reason I saw like lights to love it here
we go
leveling up are you gonna kill the big
rat yeah we can try to kill the big rat
all right level 25 feels good okay let's
do a yeah I I don't think that will ever
happen your boy I don't think they'll
report blood-borne to Xbox that's a
that's a Sony exclusive man no they'll
never do that best you can hope is that
DC they all know but best you can
opposite they'll do like a new version
of it I would like I mean I don't I
would like a pro update I would like
something maybe when the PS 5 comes out
they'll do like a spy is probably like
what another year out maybe I feel like
or sometimes with someone telling me
like 2020 is like an anniversary that
kind of things someone was saying like
it's an anniversary it's too soon I
think
it would feel more appropriate if we
didn't have the pro in there and the ex
yeah I would have been Tuesday I would
have been salty to be honest at 5:00
like right I it was like I just bought a
pro please let's not do this yet right
can you even get to the rat from here oh
is that that spot that you were avoiding
this time
Marit giant rat nope
oh here we go time for some rat
extermination potentially that's weird
all the rat might have been a different
way this gets me to the boss though yeah
let's do it
sounds like a great way to end this
scream a couple boss fights this other
guy that we've never seen before once
you kill him though he doesn't respawn
look at him dancing camera Grandal time
I can't wait to fight on dude I want to
you know that's like the one thing I do
want to do though because I've never
thought I was furious but I remember
getting his armor and I was like oh and
through my jab this is the [ __ ] right
here is funny you've at this point she
played our choices maybe one of the most
like redone boss fights there have been
so many versions of artorias like to had
one called the loss center 3 had like
two versions of it
there's the abyss walk yeah those are
basically version operatories and then
slave night Gale at the end of the final
deal so yeah he's kind of got something
yeah he's got some worries as well so
people really like artorias he was a
pretty cool dude that's what you get for
viewing the Vista it is at least you
didn't get full poisoned wow that didn't
even trigger you to be worried about
those boxes it would have triggered the
crap out of me I'm dumb Artorius heart
says Felina yeah
holy smokes did not know that that's how
many we had so far yeah that's cool this
number
look at that nice read yeah yeah gonna
gonna make you uh gonna make you do the
finish this boss maybe we'll see we'll
see we'll see
was it alright of all the days today is
actually probably the least busy this
week so we could oh that's fair we could
do it if you wanted now there's a little
bit more yeah
frogs something come across the frogs
yeah
also yep there's don't get that don't do
that don't fall there do you actually
have to do like the jumping animation
you do ah dude I've never like practice
they're always very cumbersome and I
never really liked it okay so hi-ho
silver they fixed it a bit in later ones
and made it easier but yeah like I never
likes doing it
Gayle greater than all bosses lo Gayle
Gayle is probably one of the hardest he
was a shortcut that back to where I came
from cool
Maria is best boss like Maria's lady
Maria is one of my gehrman was also
pretty good I thought I don't know one
of the first things I did at GameSpot
was actually do like a Dark Souls
ranking list that's my own basically of
cost is the souls version of Kratos what
I don't know what that means AB Reedus
was rough a real talk
rough cost I had troubles with orphan he
wasn't that rough for me but that's
because I was overloaded
I remember I helped Dan Rikard kill
arenas because he was struggling on it
orphan sucks
I think orphan is too - ruff ruff he's
fine I got the gun staggers on him at
some point
sister freed is a fun yeah oh dude these
guys yeah oh man these guys sucked in
three weren't they near the fair and
keep at least like you don't get it
missed it after the fact like no no they
have the mist I know but like you've
kind of been in it know and like you're
not getting like hit by it I was getting
hit a little bit who did get hit a
little right in the brand the eyeball
Wow the smoke particles look way better
I'll take your word for a bitter eye
what's up Dobby how are you doing Gigi
says dark Oh Gigi indeed oh yeah you're
still good
yes okay I'm okay now you probably gotta
get out especially not that bad it's way
worse in Dark Souls 3 probably it's way
worse in Dark Souls 3
but imagine playing this for the first
time you had no idea what yeah that's
fair that's 100% fair
I don't discredit that I'm just saying
[Music]
dude I remember that [ __ ] ruining my
life in in three where I was just like
this freakin sucks it's alright we got
the ring of the evil I planned
100% planned when we fell there oh yeah
some HP that was worth I don't it was
like Thomas on purpose I would say
right in the boot oh hello boss or
thinking about yeah that's what I used
to do too when I enter the room I spam
the target lock and that would sometimes
tell you if there's something above you
the ring sucks what seems fine we're not
wearing anything else it's fine oh
what's his name was what's her name was
pretty tough for the first time when I
had to deal with him I died a lot of
times he's got the great the moonlight
sword or sky oh yeah he's probably one
of the hardest bosses not Lawrence its
Ludwig Ludwig
my favorite weapon the moonlight
greatsword No
Ludwig is coldly polite it was so good
and all of the all of my blood learn
play through because they know that's
the one handy version was really good
and the two hand version was also really
good we could have made know if we can't
actually buy what we can get the
moonlight greatsword in this game oh
that is a reoccurring weapon in almost
every souls game I think it's me
Broken Sword Hill is still better l
megalo sure Jam one day
yeah so for PC it is the 25th and
there's a discount for those that own
the prepare to try edition on PC
[Music]
yeah he didn't actually drop the sword
that's fair Johnny you had to get the
badge which there's actually the
interesting thing about it is there's
multiple ways to get it
so in mine I killed him right though
great that in blood-borne or the holy
great soil there's that's in the base
game if I recall you know not not lewd
wigs but the moonlight sorry someone
like yeah there's multiple ways you
could get it you could either kill him
or if you wore the right garments like
like priest type robes you could
actually talk to him and he'll give it
to you is what I what I heard too
because then he would think like oh
you're one of my followers type things
and like here you go whatever but it's
also you can just yeah you could just go
you can just go man that's what I did
the waterfall looks better as well
this is the remastered version on ps4 a
disaster just a normal piece for narpro
but the frame rates the same as John
we've mentioned on both and the only
thing you're really gaining out of the
pro is 4k yep
versus Ludwick the beast do you have
both twitch and YouTube chats open yes I
do
what's up my killer mug shot come on
what if we just got like blood-borne -
it's like part of the PS 5 or something
launch title I watched I am give me the
give me the blood give me the whatever
they like exclusive console one could
only hope I think like me you and Mike
like come on I'm going to come on like I
knew that the shadows died twice thing
was not even blood-borne related but I
went down that rabbit hole of like is
there any chance any chance that this is
one point to amuse them I don't think it
is I'm pretty sure there is that door
over there can you turn off motion blur
someone asked sorry to cut you out there
sure let's check okay watch out surprise
yeah bitter Isis I think Jobs died twice
his attention reboot I agree the only
other thing that kind of made sense to
was they they had a like older kind of
horror game that might fit the same
aesthetic because it was like the same
with like a similar feudal type thing
but I wouldn't be shocked if it's tenchu
I really hope they show something at e3
but they were like I don't know we might
not find out something until like later
they using this year for all we did
being something completely new mm I
think I'd be cool too there's something
I like about blood-borne is just how
like kind of one off it is and it's like
uniqueness so this is like hey it's
another Souls type game but it's like
completely different setting and I'm
totally for that Oh have one yeah shadow
sighs twice was at entry reference
apparently like one of the bosses in the
one of the games set basically says that
shadows that
which is another reason why people think
it's tenchu but it's but they could also
be leaning into that yeah
chabela 23 says at least we have -
branding gameplay at e3 yeah I'm curious
to see what that even looks like we've
seen so many CG trailers we still don't
really understand like what exactly is
going on like that'll be cool yeah I
need to see someone holding a controller
I need to like to you why I need
something
ya know what that is as a video game
Hassan says sadly fromsoft has made none
of the good Tenchi games jack wiley
who's excited for new siege operation
there's definitely some people in our
habits that are excited
less sage pair operation Parabellum your
shortcut is where that staircase is
behind you just so you know okay people
are saying yeah that's what I said will
lead us to blight town but we need to
beat the boss
this dude is the Crystal shield if I
recall yeah
crystal shields really good problem is I
don't think you can upgrade it or like
its upgrades are really limited if I
remember but you could burn Souls I buy
it if you really want to okay for now
what kind of an arm but comer says he
says hopefully we will see gameplay
pradesh I feel like you have to this
year if they're gonna say anything about
Dutchess I feel like you have to we only
have to see something gameplay related
but who knows if they don't would I be
shocked
not necessarily I just feel like it's
it's a it's about time to see some
gameplay oh hey boy
what's up anyone want to place bets on
Konami showing something maybe like Pez
Jack Wally says against all your
channels really cool thanks for
responding wasn't expecting that keep up
the great work
thank you for not only stopping by today
we're checking out all the other stuff
we do of course if you guys didn't know
that we go live every day at 11:30 as
well as a lemon a.m. for GameSpot daily
where we try to provide you the biggest
news in 30 minutes or less at 11:00
that's at 11:00 a.m. Pacific at 11:30 we
will generally be playing you know stuff
we get early or you know some of the
other like I'll say it lifestyle games
that have weekly updates you know you'll
see us doing that sometimes we do sport
night sometimes we do you know we used
to do destiny on a weekly basis I know
that oh man what's the game that's
something's getting an update soon
that's gonna have like weekly updates
but other than you know on top of that
we play games that also get you know big
updates we'll check out those you know
either DLCs or just big updates like no
man's sky is getting a big one in July I
think which is finally gonna have
multiplayer yep so that's interesting so
yeah tune in subscribe if you haven't
already put that follow button on Twitch
so when we're live if you want to come
hang out yeah look at you why would you
even do that
I like the sarcasm in that one normally
I'd have to have a giveaway for them to
smash the like button but that I do not
know bitter I he's asking he or she's
asking do either one of you know what
the PC version will have an ambient
ambient occlusion I do not know
everything about seeing graphical
settings for the that and says it makes
me so upset
rushan that says neo 2 would also be an
equally important PS 5 launch title as
the blood work I think
I think much as I like at a neo we're
gonna get a sequel yeah I'm just saying
as much as I like neo
I think blood-borne has just got a
bigger pool then neo but you know III
wouldn't be shocked if they did do a neo
2 or something like that
ringback William aka Geralt Geralt of
Rivia
yeah oh we're gonna probably find out
some you know we're hoping to find out
some cyberpunk stuff you know like yeah
who knows hopefully fingers crossed that
could be cool I'm just checking for
stuff like this and also delaying the
inevitable fighting the boss don't worry
you got it
we'll see how you fare and then we can
use that as a judgment on how long right
I kind of don't remember the strategy
with this guy that one oh you're gonna
remember real fast yeah let's find out
here you go
we turn up the audio
and so too
today
Oh
looks real fun this boss is brutal too
many team so many teeth did you kill the
mage up top no we didn't I'm getting the
pop oh you did
okay oh why does it make it harder I get
he'll shoot at you time to kill the
gaping dragon at first it kind of
reminded me of a Garros or from Monster
Hunter but then not really
where's anime dark souls by the way you
mean code Bane don't know when and I
think it's suppose to be this year but I
don't know when they don't have I would
really stay don't China so do they go to
Blighttown
that's what I want to see now we haven't
gone to by the time we're trying to get
there yeah we beat this guy with the
boss so we're gonna try to get there
however I can't point you in the
direction of Dave Jewett's oh yeah feels
good this is a big now wonderful I love
it I'm gonna give you let's say I'm
gonna give you 10 attempts is that fair
that's fair I think 10 attempts and we
given 10 attempts that doesn't count
we're starting it doesn't take that long
to get we're starting that 10 attempts
from now we get there I'll show you by
time if we don't yeah you know the
gaming dragon 1 and whatever yeah so you
have Blighttown we have light town
gameplay up actually if you were curious
so if you just didn't want to wait for
all that all all of this boss killing to
happen you could just watch the blade
town clip that we have up on gamespot
calm or youtube.com no that's not even a
thing youtube.com slash GameSpot or
GameSpot comma words words are difficult
sometimes cut his tail first to get a
cool weapon yep that is a Dark Soul
staple always get the tail off man I saw
you cut the tail off of like one of
those gargoyles earlier and that blood
animation is pretty that great
generation blood this is like some
almost mspaint blood right now but
whatever do troll set a block on this
boss folks yes
you're correct you want to do the walls
all right here we go
you need to craft the pickoff oh this is
the tail cut boss they're all of any
boss with the tail gargoyles we're gonna
try Rishon I don't know you got ten
tries what I get back
get those iframes going right in the
tail how do you like that
I hate jumping bosses in these games
Oh lewd wigs yeah wait is that [ __ ] like
the camera would just like spaz out
sometimes and it's like come on man like
give me a chance
oh he's angry right in your front foot
good ol iframes everyone loves iframes I
can't see the yago says the FPS looks
lower here question mark I don't know I
haven't seen anything so I mean I was
surprised if the bosses at least dipped
a little bit mid Matt and how exactly
does one cut the tail with a spear all
right still sharp though he poked it to
death he poked it until it comes off
I feel at least this area Oh No it's big
yeah it's big at least compared to like
Ludwig's where it was like more like a
square room that was not so great yeah
yeah that's that's kind of biggest thing
with the boss is just like the area man
he is so he's got such a elongated body
we're streaming in 60 how are in your
tail Oh watch out can you I roll through
that or are good iframes work through
that think you can I'm just don't no
worries I mean I'm curious that's all I
want to say you can do that plus there
was a boss I always used to do that with
he's hungry through the tail this is
just like Monster Hunter Fridays yeah
exactly except I'm not Ben but close
enough you guys are not equipped for
this how dare you
well there's it get harder as uh at some
point no I could probably like you have
a p2 kind of thing this game doesn't
really do that that often the way the
later games do there's not really many
second phase bosses
hmm could I recall anyway
River monster hunter fries yeah that's
kind of true yeah
please for now we have downgraded from
been to take that's kind of fair one
it's hard to replace been in Japan Janko
you know you don't simply replace a Ben
Janka no it's the same way all the way
through things Dark Lord all right so
it's a patience game every bit so it's a
big ol waiting game throw-up toxin nah
man this is an upgrade thanks Ben
nobody else seems to feel that way
though
some dead man people really don't love
the spear no port very anti sir yeah
yeah they're not about speed life I
guess spear thinner I says I do think I
do
I think this version looks great oh yeah
we need battery on all that gear
hey what's up so I don't hang around
there because out of this
where you goin what is this beer ever
done to you yeah that's fair exactly
what has it done to you
okay that grape poking great poke
except for that okay that's good
that's what we're fine with that it's
not like lewd wigs you have to be always
didn't get hit if we got hit we would
have fell all right I will I will Kindle
the fire somebody said okay so I was
like is it possible they nerfed this
boss I just replayed on a couple days
ago and it was very hard to lure him
into that moves out I think we're just
getting lucky yeah I think so too I mean
I'm not aware as far as I know they
never mentioned us anything about
fostering Rockman bionics is just stick
with the spear just to stick it to those
anti spear people I'm used to
blood-borne it's like yeah well you're
you're like minigame generation no
damage is too low that's correct
oh look at this Yolo life he's confident
in this run whoa why why would you even
pop the divine blessing meds
oh yeah got it
so now what do you or you just go for
his feet man yeah cuz it's like whatever
you go for whatever oh this is great
good damage solid sometimes it's just
about getting sustained damage you know
we're still gonna poke him in the butt
the remnants of his tail this is great
now because he can't like be with you
yeah that was like probably the most
scary move that I've seen him do sure
yeah yeah but that's fine but I'm just
saying like everything all things
considered though like everything else
seems energy bull just wanted to run
like a goofball or slam his face into
the ground that's good too or I guess
mouth or body haha you have no tail
still good did they upgrade their spear
at least four plus five no we did not
I'm like plus two which is why I'm doing
so little damage oh no it's called it's
called slow and steady wins the race
how do you think the turtle did it huh
you think you think he upgraded his
speed yeah you think he upgraded his
spear to five why would he do that
your armor is pretty heavy that's why
your role is slow yeah I made it
actually maybe it's that that bag that
o'clock bag helm we have one yeah taking
the shield off actually would help a
little it's fine but I was specifically
referring to like the something about
the like the button pressed you accident
oh you mean like the like response yeah
it seems a little bit slower then like I
remember being a little quicker response
the weapon is upgraded yeah yeah it's a
little bit upgrade it's not like massive
you know this is good we're we're slow
and steady like I said if I remember
above 25 is a slower yeah he well when
we tried earlier I'm pretty sure John
Luke tried to aim for less than 25% oh
this is not so great though that's good
this is good this range a strong side oh
yeah because of like the shield and
she'll don't worry if he's angry I
haven't seen now on that one's new
just watch out for all this random stuff
nope feel good
this dream the little turtle that could
this dream in a nutshell yep that's us
the little turtle oh there's the vomit
oh that's new
daddy's a lot of vomit actually yeah but
he does have a pretty big mouth I
suppose no problem
oh oh you're still you're still alive
it's fine you got nothing you got
nothing you got nothing but great play
left in you oh jeez
immaculate immaculate cool you could
ditch the shield at that point but
whatever it doesn't matter now papa
humanity so I'm saying Papa humanity
that's what someone said oh you ready
you do have a humanity oh god this is
not gonna look my anxiety oh we have 12
that's so many yeah yeah it's like you
know it's like an ember baby it's like
an ember you can use an ember baby good
shouts chat thanks Jess I got a free
second life yeah guys the wise decision
necklace whoo let's go says chevelle oh
I I agree let's go get hyped get stabbed
in the butt yeah one more for good
measure
Oh hamat okay
good he doesn't seem so yeah see he's
not as bad as Ludwick cuz he it seems
like he just goes into the air and then
falls down he doesn't really comes back
down he doesn't he doesn't really track
you this boss influence we wait we don't
get cocky kid that's bear yeah we're
gonna need two more combos probably kill
them maybe three whoo that was an
unfortunate miss I get out yep yeah I
might take two more now
he's not doing vomit
oh we're still good someone's calling me
can't answer its of 802 number someone
focused John Luke
Ludwig would have just raised his sword
and enter this funny oh yeah okay okay
and I start a little window of
opportunity there yep this is good
though usually chills out after he goes
for his little sprint here are cheeky
we're trying to get that last one in
what do we need them to do we need to do
like a face slam with no vomit there you
go
finish this fight for the people John
Luke Oh
oh my god Wow
I got I got too cocky at the ends that's
how you die in Dark Souls eat your heart
out stream Wow damn
alright John look it's totally your
fault I don't know you want to kill it
man that was funny
oh that was really really funny I will
say not in this case specifically I have
died many a time to thinking that you
could just get all those swag yeah you
know man like you're like I'm just gonna
finish him off with like X amount of
hits and then like you don't do the math
right and it's just like ya know sure he
had that other than the fact that he
like I mean like okay at the other day
it was your fault because you were
overzealous and he mismanaged you know
stamina whatever hundreds but he was
literally one hit away did you know if
he had done what he had did 90% of the
fight which is like near stay near the
hind leg he would not have died to a one
shot there I think I gave you guys the
classic Dark Souls experience which is
you get really cocky at the end
pretty much you have any fire or
lightning buffs okay you want to take
your shield off then since you're never
gonna use it anyways yeah let's do that
the greed is real
you just got Dark Souls yep you know
what it was you know what it was he was
like I want the stream to last a little
longer forget every one of the viewers
here and just to show you this godlike
role that we have now so you know we
figured why not why not do it again why
not just one more time no problem
alright now you got a poke his tail off
again huh mmm no oh car now the tail
comes back but you keep the weapon yeah
but you want to poke his tail off so so
it's easier oh sure some in Salerno no
no no no no you will fight him like a
man all right you will fight him like a
man's for that spear oh yeah mm-hmm
pick up your humanity did you do that I
have humanity okay I mean pick up my own
Souls
haha I think greed comes closest to
second when you're fighting a Ledge boss
how is that getting cocky that's being
dumb and shakin definitely Oh but
obviously I feel that as the same thing
so this will be a little bit harder to
start but once we get his tail off
obviously we should be good no jolly
co-op no jolly cooperation okay this is
good right no it's not
I thought he was gonna do that the face
man slam
Fight Like a Man
what dumb I don't get that one but all
right sir
flipped at your hugging for extra damage
ledge box claims everyone at least a
dozen times
this is gameplay of the remastered and
he news on the suite version no nope you
got nothing on that front the back legs
will shoot back pretty far when walking
yeah it just didn't look like it though
but yeah its body becomes a hips box as
it moves just like touching the sen's
fortress boulders ah fair use your trap
card Yugi if only I had a trap card this
is where I would use my polymerization
card I use pot of greed work that card
is banned by the way notice yeah the
best was I recently it was like maybe
one or two months ago there was like a
somebody I forgot who it was some
streamer that died to Exodia turn one
this is like what how do I sell the
stock Estus flask
[Music]
firekeepers salsa someone says the spear
is the worst weapon in game we're aware
now what about the oh the watch we call
it the short the hilt of this
oh my troll says hitting the head does
more damage I'm sure it does but I gain
real detail like I feel like if you get
rid of tail it kind of makes it like
pretty trivial yeah it does do about
thirty more damage
it looks like 30 to 40 more per hits
than like hitting the tail here
yep that was good mm-hmm blazing Bojo
says the spirit just overall has poor
damage but it's more of a defensive that
was good does good read when he slams
his head go for it he does more damage
yeah we know we just like to make where
we're trying to make this fight as safe
as possible
supposed to be oh is that a clip of him
dying I mean I guess in that case since
you had to run all the way around you
probably were better going off for his
head there the last time probably but
here you're good there is jackpot pot of
greed
I activate kuriboh in defense mode
stupid kuriboh
saved him so many times what
probably not yeah not worth
yeah it's only half off on PC if you
don't prepare to die right 40 if you
don't correct
Johnny Rogers thank you for okay what's
up
use your ultra instinct on it uh yeah
only we trained to learn ultra instincts
one day out I'll have a chat with Goku
and maybe he'll teach us all train
stings for gaming it wants this last
fight know if anything I should be liked
twitch in YouTube chat please I need
your power as possible alright
but
one more time to get out of Dodge koku
doesn't know how to use ultra instinct
either technically I mean yeah I guess I
don't know I didn't watch enough super I
only know that he uses it as like you
know to fight zero or whatever Oh
that's that's where the Chatwood a prize
that you should rolled probably that's
where I say you should probably rolled
all right this is your literal last
chance here sorry dudes
you died yeah what why blame me it's
literally not my fault hey blaming you
know Google is that he thinks that I'm
the reason that you died there
definitely not no definitely not that
was definitely me this is what's hard so
hard about this boss for mean he has so
many hits I mean it's like that uh like
that classic it's a long it can be a
long fight so it kind of makes you feel
like you can do stuff you know or like
it wears you down a little bit so if
you're not you know really just laser
focused the entire time anything could
potentially kill you yes should have dot
PNG yeah rip no we are using the spear
yeah we don't care about everyone's hate
for the spear we've killed at least one
boss on the stream with a spear and we
should have technically killed another
boss with the spear if we oh yeah see
look John we literal look Yolo right now
it's like I'll show you damaged you want
damage we'll give you that DPS I mean
hella at least the tail whip is only
like a half half a life you know
damaging maneuver
BTI aw awesome says this blah sponge
attacks you whereas the three bosses
before this you plunged attack them it's
true yeah how does that feel on your
little head there they're two whips look
at this guy playing smarter now stab
back faster than the eye
oh we will I think you can get a little
maybe two it's time to get out of Dodge
it's pretty good though cuz those two
hits are the equivalent of your three to
the tail or back end of him so look at
this guy real risky for wow he's going
for five this guy's this guy's gettin
greedy he literally has activated his
pot of greed we are running on a ps4 Bob
snob and this is the urn of the run oh
my god you I like it you know what I
like it I like it
you've learned what you can get away
with and you're just like you know what
screw it screw it I can't read that
David it appears I believe that's Korean
Anya haseo
and that's all I got for you the urn of
greed k noir says you've got this one as
long as he doesn't get one shot okay
he decided to take a break there mid-run
plate
I guess so he feels bad for us and the
stream and he's like you're using the
spear I'll give you a chance I'll give
you a chance I'll be well be nicer grab
your souls back
our souls are not our concern right now
I'll use much strong what maneuver is
this oh it's a vomit
laser focus like chem 7 in the NBA
Finals that's the face he has on right
now I hope he I hope that what you're
saying is true bitter eye
acid
this is good like we're going to you
know we're doing some damage to the
front then we're doing some damage to
the back this is this has been a lot
faster how many times has he died I was
gonna 420 no way I was gone for 20
minutes oh we've got three times we
literally had him was it first try
second second try we had him at like 1
hp and he decided to one-shot us instead
so yeah we're on try three last one he
got he got dunked on about 80% of his HP
essentially the only good about this run
though so much so that he's gonna go for
an extra stab
yep
okay just yeah just don't normally yes
you can get three hits in now one was
ellipse that's fine that's fine
and like the back you usually get three
or four unless he decides to like swing
his tail at you even if he does it's
usually only half half your life so we
could please get one shot at akin no no
more getting one shot it here we go
someone says taking zero damage don't
yep you know he's gonna you're gonna get
a perfect run here don't get hit all
right line it up yeah zero damage no SS
blast needed spear we are good oh good
job you want to really quickly show them
Blighttown
curious about the play time will show
you by town incoming there's my soul's
okay so now you got a show play time oh
yeah we're on it we'll do it we're on it
GG oh my gooood did it downloaded says
philanthropy he was downloaded I guess
he I guess if anything John we've just
had to play riskier it's going slow was
not the way I guess I was wrong all
along chat slow and steady was not the
way
all right
am I crazy where is the
maybe it's here yeah
try Dark Souls I'm keyboard mouse pure
terror oh yeah oh you could also just
homeward bone I could they actually
would have been no damage runs starting
now nope
sorry let's cash on these souls real
quitting go level and go to Blighttown
check out the scenery for like five ten
minutes and then we'll call an industry
a successful one and going longer than
the better along with you but could have
gotten a Quelaag you know sometimes you
gotta you guys just take what you can
get great logs actually the last place
after we that we could show anymore so
we're fine sm4 to pay for it'll be
available on Friday the 25th if you have
the prepare to die edition you get it
for 20 but if you don't it is 40 39
anyone
Oh whereas Ajit is saying keyboard and
mouse is actually superior if you learn
to play a properly
interesting that's the first person I've
ever heard say that prepare yourself
flight town will chew you up with that
spear oh yes depending on which way he
enters in the sphere is actually
probably not a good idea with light down
but this is where I could go by the
bonfires look good yeah I could buy the
crystal
well did you you still have oh you're
gonna have to pop something I think to
get in 6000 we're 3 hunt to 210 sure oh
that was only 4,000 I bet the shield was
6,000 alright we're switching weapons or
so dramatic
alright we're out of spear life guys you
finally get to not be up so spear a
spear haters yeah we should use those
brick and broken straight swords look at
that that's got like no range yeah
farewell spear we knew you well alright
ok here we go what if it does that
lighting thing still yeah it just
doesn't like it's really dark in here
it's like you're in a different town man
thought you know
now blades him there it is so what's
hold just hold circle with no down
directional thank you
I forgot has mentioned that a long time
ago but hey you weren't wrong
oh there was a letter there yeah
Oh butcher kind of classic classic
Blighttown all right
not even the actual hard part of light
oh just the beginning I love it now that
I'm falling thumbs up
ah good [ __ ] welcome to Blighttown
alright let's at least get a little bit
further in than that I agree
who made all the dark doors and Dark
Souls so heavy he's a good question
ledge boss claims another life
nothing like dying in 60fps it's tough
but I'm still gonna blame Tay for that
one yep I told John Luke to block in
your hedge it's true so you know if you
go all edges that's the problem it's
just being near ledge and blocking clip
it it's all edge I died more to follow
I died where to falling in Dark Souls
than any other thing is I think what
Husson says than any other method
foolish the rogue says the same yep
mm-hmm
scam yes we got scammed scammers that
guy was such a Ledge Lord yeah worth
worth just not falling off the ledge oh
my lord this guy has a lot of lies yeah
Wow look another one came home on time
so long you can do it very these ogres
their jokes
I don't know about that man huh I just
don't see my cherien yet he might be
tough to try to start caring now yeah
one day I should just learn how to do it
today is not that day though no the
greatest enemy in Dark Souls is the
ledge that is true Thank You artorias of
the abyss
all right if you die again it'll be as
much as he died to the gaping sweep
trick and then after that I'll do a
Blighttown no no damage run right yeah
no damage yeah third time was a charm
you know oh this is the third time isn't
it just go to his back and back stuff I
think he was trying but um was carrying
is so easy I see I not sure if I
actually no no I'm just
I called them out for spelling easy like
I see I know okay I was saying I
actually I just never bothered to like
learn that it is once you learn right
like I could parry the those big ogre
dudes in blood-borne all day now no
column man this guy oh oh oh
All Right see ya word he I was worried I
was on victim ya know he fell victim to
the ledge lot ledge bought this time oh
my god there's three of them mmm feels
good
there's a button that lets you roll are
you sure no don't don't roll our scrubs
man I was just rolling the chat John we
don't give them what they want
how's that feel crystal shards good
block good block good block
little edge boss is a fickle mistress
okay their trick can be a pain if can't
parry so don't worry we're probably not
gonna get at that point so you're gonna
try what okay I thought you were like
practicing a parry there because you're
actually gonna try I was like no let's
just backstab man let's just give him
these but stab her yeah but stebih
but step ah I was just kidding never
parry backstab all the way boom
Shakalaka
oh you guys are so bad once you're off
it like away from a Ledge it's really
like the ledge is the worst part of my
time
oh we dung pie delicious and the poison
the poisons also bad yeah
large Club one of the greatest weapons
of all time what's up dude oh he went
for a grab oh come on toxic I know
you've got a heal like spam heal right
now spam heal I should I should just ban
it lesbos does not discriminate everyone
falls like yep I know Britney Spears hmm
Britney Spears
toxic
good song why are you going to play town
this way because the alternate way you
can go to Blighttown I'm not allowed to
can show it that correct
but yes yeah he literally answered his
own question like right after are you're
not allowed to let show that way yes
we're not what yep
cuz yeah there's a completely different
way in the boy town is this your first
time wanting Dark Souls not his first
time gonna be mine
I haven't played Dark Souls in a very
long time is toxic giving less damage I
don't know I've never seen before but it
didn't seem that bad there I mean like
it's granted he was already like low on
life yeah uh I don't really know I
haven't looked at don't like a
side-by-side comparison maybe this guy
will fall off for me again
no that was the second guy that fell off
aha
no one puts one of these guys in the
corner except you not fun this is not
blood-borne you don't heal on a tech I
know that but he needed to heal like
right away to overcome the toxic effects
that he had there this is a scary
situation yeah just get stuck on each
other I love it mm-hmm it's not great
peace is play town fixed well yes show
you hopefully so we're trying to do yeah
yeah good trick everyone wasn't really
cheap but good aggression we're doing it
for the dump eyes really we're farming
dumb pie right now that's why we died
are you just gonna shortcut it can you
is that part is that where you need to
go I don't leave me there
all right yeah sure shortcut that's a
shortcut oh my god that was it that was
very much so perhaps you needed a
running start maybe maybe I could have
[ __ ] that was so funny
damn are you gonna try again okay oh no
that's fine I feel like you could have
you could have left on that thing
oh no you definitely could have I just
like you wanted to hit him I wanted I
was trying to do like a hit thing and
then I you jump there yeah yeah I
thought I thought I could do it we're
trying to get the old two per one
dropped down hit a guy land what we want
to but you know my favorites still you
know still happens well that escalated
quickly
yeah when the dumb becomes pi hmm
platforming is the darksouls best
feature mm-hmm a Chevelle is 23 he says
you can also watch a feature by digital
foundry the tucks that shows Blighttown
yes yeah they have a really good Rick
down video
right there buddy oh-ho-ho I don't like
that at all nice
those guys are pretty decent souls there
500 a pocket died here for some reason
[Music]
where's the amazing chest ahead side so
because we're flying there are no how
far are you guys allowed to show I think
like we can fight Quelaag yeah and then
that's an interesting sound what will
you do here
slow and steady it's like you should I
mean this like autocue though yeah come
on watch out for the other shoe you're
good you should have those iframes
oh man and blood-borne that would have
knocked this guy on his on his butt oh
good you're good he's yelling in the
background it looked like a play about
the same thing okay
all right tip lights out we hopefully go
I mean we're technically there but like
to something more chuggy
or does it already usually just show
once you get to the part where you can
see the bottom that's that's where we
can't show that probably Roman what is
it I'm melting lava nope
can't show underneath quelaag so we
can't show that part there was a dude
here so gonna go where did he go
let's just try and take out this blow
dart man yeah
these guys suck all right some purple
moss
I should have quit that after wait this
is the remastered yes on ps4 normal ps4
regular juicer
oh I keep ur soul shoot
the frames are certainly dropping a lot
looks like pieces called me out on
called me y'all not upgrading my Asus
class keep your totally rikes I didn't
realize I had a fire keep your soul
didn't need it if you're asking me I
have no idea myself yeah good ol wide
slash there okay door by the dart man
right here that is the bottom the
framerate would already be chugging at
this point think I can make that jump I
don't think so I'm just gonna say no
every time you're asking about jumping
why are they making so secretive this
game is so old I don't know but I mean
part of it could be that there is a day
one patch coming so maybe some of it is
that we're talking about we're
specifically like that's weird up there
goes nothing WOWY classic Blighttown
can't wait to play this haunting I
probably won't be hello small dose to
small doses
also I barely or want you to heal it's
real confusing oh okay I can do that
you got JT got it that doesn't seem like
the right way it's not all the way down
there oh those boys look at that kind of
spidery anyway welcome to dark town so
delicate I'm waiting for like that one
wants her to jump at you yep yep yep Oh
perfect totally worth it what was it
just some humanity yeah had fun peace
later John Rogers well I never knew that
floor can break well now you know and
now we know and knowing is half the
battle that way that way across the
rickety looking bridge yep oh this is
great yeah this is exactly what I want
to do in a Dark Souls game just cross a
rickety bridge at what point does a dog
just come running at you or something or
blow door blow dart guy start shooting
stuff I ain't got my shield oh there's a
rat over there or something
oh it might be one of those creatures
you're talking about it's freaking out I
know I just
come on sweep the leg in this game
knowledge is power
I agree big man it is that's why the
first playthrough is always like the
most
now that doesn't that's just praise the
moon don't think it does I mean you got
to be able to get somewhere from there
and yeah it's just gonna be stuck trying
to remember the layout of Blighttown is
like a nightmare oh we got a ladder oh
where this where the dark guy was I'm
gonna be real salty
oh yeah it is this is this the time to
call it we could call out here if you
want I think no I think this this is
this is as good as it's gonna get unless
you want to like run through some place
is there like we could try and see how
far down I can't I just go just go far
down I he convinced me it didn't take
very much convincing they're toxic
incoming Oh fire-breathing they did that
he's a cute guy though he has fire
breath oh yeah - you should equip your
Moss stuff oh you have it okay cool cuz
someone was like yeah toxic incoming
quelaag is so close I know is he really
quail eggs at the bottom yeah well then
if you get to the bottom you might as
well quelaag it up with whatever you
have that's the stipulation oh sure
that's fine sit at the bonfire I won't
save it's fine oh yes they're actually
right I should eventually go I keep
forgetting about that dangit chat he
would have had less excuses if we didn't
give him a chance thank you Thank You
Chad I almost forgot about sitting at
the bonfire that one only cures poison
not toxin fYI I'm gonna have to kill all
that stuff you just killed yeah you guys
are just stringing this stream along I
see what I see what's going on here yeah
yeah they're right if I want it's the
red one I want four
maybe that's it well disease that we go
Quelaag is female yes woman then we'll
fight her or hopefully fight her that's
the goal
see ya oh come on interesting I'm heeled
I guess I usually snipe the bastard with
a bow no toxin no problem buddy
oh oh that's a grab wow that's a lot of
damage look at that this is going
swimmingly see what happened you see
what happened you guys told him to go to
the bonfire and he's wasted three more
flasks or two more flasks than he had
just now now this fight is gonna go way
harder what in the hell is that that's
the part I'm trying to remember getting
down boy how do we know it's a boy
everything
oh you know what could you have upgraded
your Estes oh oh ladder thanks for
showing us where to go you dummy
whatever we'll take it okay we're not
booking it back hello we didn't have to
book it back cuz he's just dead I'll
just get back there
alright literal death here I'm sorry the
guy I'll be the guy you're the host yeah
that's what you didn't I'll be the guy
to rein it back in here this is his last
try upgrade everything do everything you
need to can I do here do I have to do it
at the fire link and that you I don't
remember
hey jinxed it I definitely do not jinx
it I said just go you know but hey
nobody wanted to listen to me alright
scroll up I'm not bored I just have
other things I have to do
that are work-related try to remember
how to use humanity to add to your
counter and then Kindle nobody Kindle
gets you more I'm talking about like
literally upgrading them I forget how I
do that no we're not trying to get to
the from the top bottom part we just
actually have to get all the way down
lose power of Estus flask but don't you
have to like thanks you fire link is
what someone said you can't do it at a
bonfire yes you have to go to fire link
yeah that's fine don't need it alright
forgiven never needed it to begin with
here we go okay so how do I avoid that
book because I remember not having to
fight that guy that like gross thing my
god there's a way to just avoid that
only fire keepers can up bonfires okay
that is whatever thank you watch out for
the dojo so it's the one at Firelink i
needa use come on
you only have six SS now we down five
little dance yes that's exactly what we
need another broken straight sword
[Music]
remember those guys down there yeah hey
boys I thought those guys had better
drops than that yeah well so we get past
that guy again remember Dark Lord there
was a time when the tenant ADT I was
actually like $700 or something but it
was like very short-lived that was like
two weeks ago I think back down whoever
got that got real lucky goodbye
there we go
you need the kanay do the sword in the
previous area I don't know if that helps
you in this case use black fire bombs to
kill the thing yes I used a bunch of
fireballs earlier yeah I'm gonna pick
two more I need to okay here do you have
to get by that thing to get to where you
need to get to I want to say there's
another way but I don't recall I know
binoculars will do it Kibo the squid
thing
I'll go ride the Baumann instead what up
who didn't injure doc did that haha
you'll not get my friend game watch out
areas that's not the dart guy though how
come it showed no damage
sir run past him Oh nope on this way oh
yeah let's just do this okay
small guy coming to you yeah trying
oh yeah camera yep this is great I love
I love this
oh you dodged the grab which is good
BAM from behind a safe or range whatever
no I remember now I'm totally I know
we're gonna go down here oh he is doing
damage if it's damaged water is high up
so out of screen range got it
that's a ladder yeah oh that's the boss
no it's not oh it's a fog man fog
usually tells me it's boss time ice is
way lower lower how much there's another
bonfire that's good
we were duped now there's a lot okay and
that's this is gonna get tricky I would
like to get to that bonfire
okay so I went ahead and slide down a
hill so I probably right Oh guys that
looks cool sounds like fun Oh at least
they're not that this is like so limited
space to work with
isn't that the point fire
it's definitely point run for it well he
needs to know where to run before he can
really connect and remember it's just
like the general like where am I going
just two of those guys one guy that
might have just fell off the yep slid
down watch out bow guy dart guy or
something okay Falcone Falcone oh [ __ ] I
never could say that word oh these boys
the gross come on get closer to me
please nice
and before toxic death yeah the dance
with the ledge bus this is oh hello
there he fell down oh you fell down
I fell down we're good I'm okay I'm
gonna get poison but it's fine
I remember this boss
I was watching Francis I was watching
Francis fight this thing she's a big
spider boss yeah yeah she's got fire
right she does blocking all right let's
go you got one shot one opportunity you
should probably use your humanity or
whatever oh you think I should just all
in I'm gonna you one all in chance
giving you an all in chance now the real
frames begin no frame she's a maneater
so she's kind of like that one boss in
neo
we'll do one more quelaag run we're
gonna do one I'm gonna give him one here
we go it's fair here we go
level up someone says I'm just your leg
is just alright you need the suit yeah
all right leg is in a real great place
must be real cold leg all right okay
Argo the wolf yo guys at game spot is
this already out no it comes out Friday
we're checked we're just chillin nice
glitch yeah it's okay the leg bug
persists yeah
cooking some legs what nope nope screw
that screw you Mildred does he at least
fight the monsters oh we got these giant
boys before Roxy
this is some real Dark Souls 3 friends
gonna run faster near the fairing keep
oh wow this she's up there right yeah we
close we close we close wouldn't you
care poison in there okay
oh wow is this planned calculated
hashtag calculated these boys do you
need to kill him okay that's not worth
why even wake it up okay all right we
got eight seven yeah seven of seven all
right we'll see here will fight her if I
lose I lose
Hey look at that fire yeah this fire
effects are definitely better
Mildred's meat cleavers like battle axe
but ranged it's great they are passive
oh no he touched them
kill her she will help you this is gonna
hurt she's the man Nita all right I'm
trying to remember the strats I know
she's got lava and fire whoo
so now's the time baby
how does it feel lava on both sides now
though that's bad
should have fought Mildred first now we
ain't got time for that Judas whoa yeah
that is awkwardly not hitting you
somehow Oh
nice Dodge
[Music]
yep
[Music]
that looks that's fine just a little
singe Queen leg indeed I don't know she
seems fine so far I know she hasn't
now line was it that was the AoE attack
all right just stay calm who that was
that was a scary moment there a little
baggage
okay the double sip yep yep top it off
tark son says the boss says a little
better someone else was saying that this
is a downgrade I don't know about that
this looks a lot better than what I've
seen
nice
is that that okay trying to look for the
queue for the AO AO e yeah she like kind
of goes I think she like kind of like
hunches over yeah yeah yeah you got a
lot of space a lot of space
don't worry rushan it is what it is now
the shield will just have to be where
it's at it's fine I'm not about to tell
you to take it off take it off oh if she
cuts it on the head to shoot a little
bit fire nae nae okay this is good time
Oh buddy nice Dodge
[Music]
all right getting some shades of Lady
Maria here watch out without AoE
sorry to backseat I don't know that was
like the that was like the one ender
right there that I was like I don't want
to see it happen like this
oh yeah this is good this is good
good job
great I eat out I was like a dream
probably yeah it's slow and steady here
we got it oh this is good that was not
Oh No you're good you're good you're
good
we got a watch out all right I'm gonna
give you one more cuz I feel bad but you
got caught in the legs
damn caught the legs man you gonna one
shot him her she did you dirty she did
calleded man Oh son of them mm well I
doubt my humanity anymore so I'm not
gonna get chased by that dude so we're
just gonna dad sucks that really sucks
lesson learn to get good that's fair I
cannot dispute that Oh
make sure take the shield off once I get
you gotta get past the rock dude to
sprinkle the take hurts come on come on
man why did you not use the assets he
didn't have a space to use the estus I
feel like in that situation I was get
away yeah yeah exactly
maybe this I think it was fine I think
everything was fine there I think it was
like bad luck of getting caught in the
explosion because like we I think we
knew it was coming it was one of those
things where it's like he rolled like
the roll rolled into the leg and then
it's like well what are you gonna do
that I quit what's my you're good that
is yeah look at that we're nimble don't
hit these guys please and imagine if he
hadn't hit those things earlier he would
have had two more flasks so you know all
right
go to lost izalith after can't here we
go we took the shield off
full immersion full gameplay audio no
sorry this is like getting hit by these
those little
got hit by earlier
number three and available oh come on
and cheap dad
you can have them give me one more yeah
but that you're so not you knew you knew
I knew but I couldn't gonna win left
right I probably good and probably good
all right yeah look at my record run
Sonne says you can't parry her it's true
I need to see her die yeah I do too
I mean
oh boy try recruiting the [ __ ] and
actually he had it the first time is
what you guys don't understand he didn't
not need Mildred he didn't need any of
that he was literally like one yeah he
was two hits away maybe three but I mean
if he didn't get hit by the AoE he had
plenty of plenty of time I mean it was a
kind of crappy situation though because
the lava was rolling up but I mean in
before ten hours you know I will
definitely
that that won't happen yeah
he's very fair
this is mostly good I think yeah
we have the double drink
get my name's my no souls back
[Music]
thread the needle or not I don't know
what happened there I feel like that was
not my fault I didn't look like it but
at the same time I was like maybe you
should went back to the door cuz it was
safer probably I was trying to get to
that maybe the 10 hour stream kappa
thing wasn't false cuz I don't know one
more take
yeah I know he's already running he
didn't even need me to say it so ds3 was
easy but F pontiff Sullivan yeah
Sullivan wannabe be the thing the
Sullivan is apparently if you learn how
to parry him though
yes but if you don't thank you oh why
you know where it's safe it's in here
that's what happens it's fine start yeah
I know isn't it the more all right 9
flasks was going wait someone said bring
your shield back why why I didn't use it
all right all right here we go here we
go here we go here we go here we go
that's a pretty BS move
it's implanted a meter
soles fatigue getting in skin sloppy I
agree anvil I agree he's getting sloppy
and real sloppy it's also weird I will
say sometimes the first attempt always
seems to go better than a lot of other
attempts I don't know why
[Music]
[Music]
yeah just watch out for her body when
she goes down because you can view a oe
we know thank you
it's harder to see when you're on the
side I guess because then you're kind of
like
so behind her is now looking like a safe
area
[Music]
Brava looking like jello know about that
good good very good you should have a
lot of space here
did this different AoE
oh that's kind of interesting but all
right
on point with those rolls brother thanks
bitter
someone says brighter lava I like it
Thanks
[Music]
oh ho I got greedy I know no one more
2:30 you this is your last I don't even
care how you die this is literally your
last
that's my last try I'm like I was like I
see it coming and I'm like no you are
not gonna be a little fun right now it
takes like and I was like it takes
probably two rolls to get away and I'm
like how are we playing to passive I
feel like he's doing as much damage as
he needs anything I was too aggressive
at the end there Oh last try Yolo not
scary at all it's like a nagging
ex-boyfriend one more try one more time
or girlfriend if you hug our face you
don't have to roll to avoid the melee I
was gonna ask if you're safe from that
or not but I can tell it looks like you
would get hit I have no idea
100% safe from a leaf springs swings if
hugging base but that's up to you if you
even want to take the risk
oh that kind of worked out better and
weird l better consider all things
considered that was a better because you
didn't get hit by lava
[Music]
I cannot tell okay I was like is she
about to do alien
[Music]
[Music]
nice very nice
I got nervous sir it was worried I got
like lost in her
so apparently oh I don't know about that
attack but yeah apparently that one's
safe
oh this is not so though okay just get
off of attacking them
[Music]
oh not today
oh yeah I was good
five more tries in the village theater I
think he knows what to do don't worry
man hunter I know he that he probably
doesn't have to you but just let's not
mess with his um yeah his blow back
though whatever it takes to beat the
boss it doesn't matter at this point
it's how I look at it
[Music]
look at that had time to fix his
headphones
ha ha ha ha
didn't want to say anything didn't want
a commentators curse and we did it we
did it
I was I was act I was actually gonna say
and walk into the fire I'm not even sure
game is busted look at that look at the
garbage watch that's not first try yeah
okay the game is now being fair I was
definitely not something all right
anyway yeah we ring the bell ring the
bell ring das bell and we'll end it
there was a fine stream we have 600 well
I don't know if that's accurate 699
people in YouTube thank you guys
hanging 100-plus in the twitch thank you
guys for hanging out we're gonna ring
the bell we will see the lava
there's the lava no talk to a Quay Lana
can't go underneath her chamber and it's
okay we're allowed to show this oh yeah
this is library now yo what's up October
but it's about to be not live anymore
though don't we stop here holy crud
mouth we played for three hours
oh well that explain why I have so much
work to do actually the same
for a sec
that's part of thanks $0.50 fortress
real mother
all right cool
well thanks everyone for tuning in
appreciate it
thank you John Luke for weathering the
storm and beating a couple bosses
obviously thank you for giving me the
opportunity yeah and then again we
survived luckily it paid off but thank
you guys all for tuning in we'll be back
tomorrow GameSpot daily 11:00 a.m.
hottest new stories and 30 minutes or
less for the day and then of course
we'll be back tomorrow 11:30 I haven't
decided exactly what we're gonna stream
there's so much stuff coming out
tomorrow that it could be overwatch
anniversary
it could be fortnight weekly challenges
because that happens on Tuesdays it
could be I think someone said like test
servers for like rainbow succeed you
might be in tomorrow I don't know so
there's a lot of stuff to choose from
well probably to overwatch but come back
tomorrow 11 3 you'll find out for sure
and yeah check this game out if you want
to Dark Souls remastered it comes out
Friday
it's a 39.99 yet for console if you
don't already own it on PC it's also
$39.99 if you don't own it but if you
own to prepare to die edition then it's
half off believe it's $20 yeah do you
know if we're doing a review I don't
think we are not I'm aware yeah all
right well thanks everyone and see you
guys next time
[Music]